weapons when you mix sports criminals
the ethereal and wasteland and a
wasteland
you get pile wall on a big pyre oh god
hello I'm Dave joined by some more
we're playing pyre yes which just to get
us to formally disclosure either way
pyre is developed and designed by
supergiant games one of the developers
on this team is well none other than
Greg Kasavin former GameSpot editor as
before my games about time yeah GameSpot
a legend I grew up reading and watching
Greg Kasavin he's one of the people that
made me want to do this job and they
play one of his now I'm playing one of
his games with me yeah so supergiant are
well known at this point for making
games are wildly different from other
games and their own games yeah so they
did Bastion and then transistor and
those two have some lineage between them
but they like action games and one's a
little more like strategic almost odd
hiest like now we have a sports office
games weird but I really like it yeah
it's so cool I played about three or
four hours of it yeah I think I think I
played four hours now yeah and like I
was surprised to learn that the amount
of narrative in there yeah they actually
reminded me of we talked about earlier
banner saga yeah it's got its got like
licks of banner saga like you said it's
got the transistor and Bastion DNA in it
yeah I love the design of it we're gonna
go head to head sweet I've not played
against another person yet no we should
be certain it's quite hard to explain
the game you'll get it what you'll
understand once we start playing but um
it's basically magic rugby kind of yeah
it reminds me a little nasty I was gonna
say it's it's hard to explain because it
really is a beast of its own but yeah I
need to extinguish Tam's pyre by getting
the orb into his fire and Tammis to do
the same to me yeah so three on three
3v3 mean fires are essentially the goals
both sides of the map
and you basically need to pass it around
move towards the opponent's pyre yeah
and then slam dunk this or that fall
from the sky I'm the greens yeah you're
the oranges oranges okay
I think I'm called the pie hearts oh
there's loads of characters this is more
characters than I've seen in the actual
yeah same I'm just gonna go yeah
oh so we got okay so you got I pick you
pick I think you feel okay so I'm gonna
count pick you by picking head with I'm
gonna pick jewe Dario because she's the
best character she's pretty cool I'm
gonna try someone different so I've only
unlocked up to yeah I think up get here
yeah is there was a last character I
unlocked so I'm gonna pick you've named
her faith yeah
not Bey yeah I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
base call that three guys you start with
I'm gonna I'm gonna mix it up and pick a
character I've not played with yet in
the main game okay which is gonna be I
think some of these aren't all
characters that you play but all they're
in yeah oh yeah that's true
because there's that that dog's paw
professor line bloody out so this ball
I've got I've not gone aura now which
means Tam can kill me if I step into his
gold aura like so
oh okay I need to write right go on son
alright so I have 13 damage first one to
get to zero losses I reckon we do best
out of three yeah
if you hold circle you can shoot your
aura at people in order to knock them
out I'm a dog now man oh here we go mate
there we difficulties in fact or getting
comfortable with not being able to move
the over to players yeah you only
control one at a time
what is this guy's ability to know mate
Oh have you though have you I was all
expecting like over this you felt picked
like wild cards oh I'm going for slam
dunks Oh
snipe though oh oh there's no one left
to protect it got it dunk it run out of
stamina so look like I was actually just
really cocky and in so when you score
with a with one of your guys you just
what happen there to my into my aura
when you scored one of your guys you
can't control him the next round here
he'll only respawn when fall over the
jump he'll only respawn if you lose
around or if you because the next round
so flowy I was close oh good narrator
and this yeah raishin is like ours it's
just noise OH
Kobe no don't run dog dog why do you why
are you still running picked up
oh oh you have a nickel me no there is
no respawns are on a call down yeah and
like the strong your character the
longer the cooldown as well I believe
can't escape that no no no no no I made
an open goal that's game is tight yeah
it's it was unexpected to see a game
that was like so intense but also like
now darah true video narrative-driven at
the same time it's yeah cuz you get like
a so awesome oh I was doing more a great
play if you get like super intense
matches and then oh that was terrible
and then like a rest by you know are you
I threw a story know jump jump yes
stamina there's well this is sneaking Oh
how's the dunk I was a fast one I'm
gonna go see characters now though
I know here we go boys here we go here
we go what I'm in no rush man why don't
I not banish you there
SIA I threw it the last second junk know
the dog good game I was gonna close up I
hearts so these the three guys you
actually start the game with yeah I cut
they've all got like yeah they've got a
team name but there's a story to them
they're like people are approaching them
and treating them they called the
Graysons rustled me no different Grayson
different night way yeah so but everyone
seems to be treating them with some a
great degree of respect and yeah and
admiring quiet because they're like the
night wings it's like a moniker that
exists in the world before them and they
basic have a summa roll of it I'm gonna
keep the color just to yeah
so the masteries I think they're on
random X I should have access to one
mastery two three four okay we'll keep
the preset talismans are like passive
upgrades you get like equipment let's
pick a map quite liked this one yeah so
keep everything as they are can we pick
our teams so there is a you play a
character called the reader yeah who is
banished into the out of the common way
yeah Nicolo sounds terrible it sounds
all for edge if you pick up the ability
to read you're done yeah like no you
know only bad guys read and then you
kind of view you learn that you can kind
of get out of purgatory or this
wasteland by completing the rights and
this is a right yeah
the right is like
the more rights you win when you win
enough right when you get to the end of
the right so you earn your freedom and
you've got to fight other teams for
their there's they've really thought
about the world and they flesh out in a
really interesting way through dialogue
and stuff and it's said another one of
those games where you can really go as
deep as you you want to go
I like that worm though he's like he's a
knight or something I think I counted
him just for his playing the demons look
so cool yeah they remind me of saga yeah
a comic book is that maybe it's just the
horns but our style is quite similar to
his lads the music is also banging
Darren Corp I think it is who does all
of supergiant's music Schumacher oh
definitely gonna get the soundtrack a
list on Spotify on the go so I've only
played as the Mike Wazowski gonna be
this arrogant looking kid counter picks
me with the same pick this random empty
space
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go Wazowski come
at me bro you girl old lady no do Millie
dad already already Biff this this is a
bad pick what what happened there ah I
was flying oh my god it's like a jump
Jesus he'll jump jump
oh my worm was so bizarre
Wow ways that oh my god this girl can
jump this girl's got hops I'm out there
my baby Oh No hold that is disgusting I
just blow my sole job it is massive
where am I going
Oh give me that I didn't throw it far
enough walking nowhere son job job job
job I'm really confused by these
abilities then nuts right splash again
dammit have I hit your goal once yet no
you basically walk there you did
actually once you walk crab to it as
well and did it that ability can go to
hell man oh my god he teleports that's
what is oh bloody ow
know your stamina back let's go it's
really frustrating when you run out of
stamina it's the worst that line it on
there that's not fair Oh
see ya how was that her just flying yeah
her ability just Trent teleports instead
of actually firing anything it's really
weird
what why don't you get that cuz I'm the
best oh man there you're a bird when you
flying I'm trying to fly than a today oh
I should ran into your bloody thing okay
Oh
decimated oh that was nice
well I don't really cool no no my fish
self what the hell did you okay okay I
understand
ah that which powerful three and they
caught it nice level plays mate oh here
we go
I don't understand how to block that I
think it needs like - into me while I'm
weird I thought what is that flowing off
my man's
I just have trained all about its Maya
that's my ability I can't like leave a
trail and then if I hit circle I walk
back to it and damage I'm on a hit
that's got a polluted oh that was close
oh that scared me I did I got to admit I
don't know what to do with this
character she's the worst someone else
for God's sake
oh it's going oh my god scared me that
really scared me
this is close mate this is close no no
no not like this no like this yes one
all I did I actually didn't expect this
game to be this intense like when you
play single-player it's tough but you
can kind of get to grips with it quite
quickly I think the fact that we don't
know our characters do a lot yeah that
adds like a an extra level all right
let's go again
which man she's so mobile I've damaged
that day this will be the decider
alright let's go let's go boys I liked
my little my what do they call him the
IMP oh yeah yeah he's a teaser as him it
reminds me like I've always wanted
anything avatar last airbender are we
doing this map again there's a really
great fictional sport in there called
pro-bending which is like using there
this is an actual football field yeah
let's go they use a they use their like
elemental ability to manipulate elements
to create this like frisbee style dodge
ball game
yeah and I've always wanted a good
version of that and this kind of comes
close to it it's almost there like I'd
love to see supergiant I know they make
their own original IP so I'd love to
mate see the maker Abbott also a
licensed game the narrator they've
always have like great narrator names I
don't there's that into the ground
it's not something there well I'm an
accuser that's the name of your team all
right
was that the one you pay a messenger him
or stave in I'm gonna go for messenger
in her a believe slight wing press
triangle to salute during a right well
you can taunt you
Amitha pam ether let's go Pamela now
truck this is the witch that you tried
ah as another which looks it's like two
variants of each character or like style
I guess someone that you use both yeah
that's that's the that's Burt rude see
I'm probably doing myself a disservice
we're not reading the she can pounce on
enemies Jesus Crone yeah doing a classic
she was good to me last game hmm I want
to try this heavy metal dog though looks
like one the high youth from the Lion
King
yeah it does that she was too good I
can't not bigger gonna win this thing
we're gonna get my boy
you said he hasn't got my stash in you
again yeah I can't believe another feel
it's wholesome now my own rookie
drinking did you just [ __ ] Orion what
are the things that you yeah ah no I
passed ah get which son me I think a me
no let us thumbs Toby there is why does
10 extra damage I don't know how you
knock him out of the air though good
what were you saying Oh
oh yeah sniped I can't get past these
imps Oh
bait bait bait yes I landed right next
to you as well I think when you use like
the landing slam attack you know this
game is to just carry on is the worst
like the hell I was shooing you as
unbelievable Oh detonated sounding even
get anything out of it
oh my days are Paul's I just chased you
as a little bit no oh my days
Oh Oh God not fair any glory may I start
on you and somehow died yes I didn't
have the aura get out of here crushing
me about oh my god on double kill there
it is boys that was gross when he left
I'm saying catch it Oh which is the
catch I couldn't see the red core she's
so fast when she's friends what'd you
say man what are you saying
oh [ __ ] what's going on oh I've got no
team yes no yes nice son oh he can't I
forgot in one of the lovely comebacks
five left five left
Oh which one which action is it oh oh
wait everyone's dead who's gonna get
back first and I can't afford to do that
oh I did it anyway by accident on that
sorry I've got a surprise
suicide backs it in what's up GG no re
as intense I'm sorry that was fun though
I was good has really fun good game well
guys like I mean if you if you want
something a bit different so if you want
to get on my and the reaction I want to
get hype I mean like this game got my
recommended yeah I can see both our legs
like rally
yeah if you want to see a more
comprehensive analysis of this game got
against what the con there's a a video
review there just showing every a he's
given a 9 out of 10 which is high praise
yeah it's thoroughly recommended from
all members of the GameSpot but he seems
except anyone who gets beaten again
again oh man all right let's disgusting
thank you all so much for watching make
sure you check out the review we really
appreciate it we look forward to hearing
your thoughts down below and obviously
make sure to subscribe
gamespot for more that's that
by this by SIA